well see my thing with women voting is I
just don't believe that you should get
the freedom to vote with without the
responsibility that comes with it I
think you should be a net taxpayer I
think you should be doing the dangerous
hard jobs that men do in society but
there some men who you go surely he
should not be allowed oh I agree with
you I think a lot of men shouldn't vote
too getting into kind of Chinese kind of
when we decide who can and who can't
vote it's dangerous T no in most of
History most people didn't vote in the
US like it wasn't it was only like
landowning males that could vote but
imagine imagine you like just look at
your last election in the states and
obviously the big um the big stolen
election conspiracy or whatever it was I
don't know enough about it so but
imagine selected people were allowed to
vote M and then you had a result that
didn't go for them if only men voted in
the last 100 years it would have gone
conservative every time